let me start by saying how much I
enjoyed the season I finished it before
coming here to talk to you guys that
second season yeah yeah I'm a big fan of
this series um what did you know when
you first got involved in this thing how
much did you know about like the arc of
the character if it was gonna be more
than one year did they tell you the
stuff no I mean I knew I had a there
were gonna be a couple of seasons but
you don't know where it's gonna go I
think the way it works at Norco says
they have a they have a main idea of how
the arc is gonna go and then they
develop you know like we get episodes as
we're shooting so we don't know where
it's going we just know the what
happened in history so you're kind of
based off the real people until you get
scripts exactly you start filming the
season how many scripts do you actually
have and how much is it sort of like
you're learning at week by week well
when you start shooting you only have
the pilot that's and then us and then as
time approaches to enter the other
episode then you'll get it a week or two
before what do you think and maybe the
answer could be nothing but what do you
think might surprise fans of the show to
learn about the making of the show um I
think that I think the fact that we
don't know where it's going even though
we have the historical facts and I think
also that a lot of the times we use a
lot of the real locations the real you
know like real people and that's very
that's very strong because since this
conflict is happening in Mexico as we
speak and it's affecting here and it's
affecting over there it's really hard to
it's really tough to shoot because you
know that what you're doing just
happened you know it's not fiction 100%
so it's really um I really like your
character
she is she takes no [ __ ] she is strong
she knows what she wants
sort of talked about playing someone
like Isabella and you know what you
enjoy about it that I'd love to be able
to have a character that allows me that
that emotion like that raw intensity
unapologetic
kind of kind of character and I think
it's very refreshing to have females
like that it on-screen like characters
like that because it gives a an image of
of it's okay for it's okay for a woman
to be angry it's okay for a woman to
want to be ambitious to have I mean not
in the way that she is or for the
reasons that she is but you know the the
main core of who she is
there's what's interesting to me is that
there is a moment
in this season where she's offered a lot
of money to sort of step away and it's
interesting because I don't wanna get
into the specifics but like there's so
many people in the show that have so
much money but they're never willing to
step away what do you think it is that
these people you know like if they you
know if you had ten million dollars a
lot of people be like I'm out I'll see
you later
you know what do you think it is it
keeps all these people in the game I
think it's different for each each
person especially coming like where they
are in society a lot of people just want
power a lot of people are looking you
know to have some kind of security with
more more money a lot of people are
addicted to you know and in this world
but I think for Isabella specifically
she's fighting for a principle which is
to be able to have her own thing to not
be at the expense of the whims of men
and because she's fighting for that it
doesn't matter how what amount of money
you offer her she's gonna keep going cuz
it's that's her that's her her moto you
know she she doesn't she's been betrayed
in the first season she was physically
abused by a men in the first season so
so she knows she knows that the only way
to to feel safe to feel you know a sense
of protection is to rice what do you
think there are a lot of like deleted
scenes and things you guys shoot that
don't actually end up on screen really
anything is there anything that you were
really sad to see go well I haven't
finished watching the second season of
course I'm ahead you're ahead of me
because ya know it takes a while for me
to watch it cuz I have all this memories
connected to it so I you know I watch an
episode I'm rewinding him you know so
but
I mean there's a I'm sure there's a lot
of things that didn't make the cut I
think in the first season I could tell
you there was this one beautiful scene
after Falcone died where we saw Isabella
mourning for her friend but then that
didn't that didn't make it in the in the
rhythm of the Edit so that I was very
sad to see that go but there's a lot of
beautiful moments yeah I'm always
curious about when Netflix is gonna
start putting deleted scenes in as like
extras because I don't think they do a
lot of that and I would imagine like
fans like myself you'd love to see it
yeah me too
one of the things is that you get to
wear and I I don't usually talk about
clothing but like I have to talk about
the clothing in the show right how much
did you borrow from set how much did I
borrow for you cuz I'd taken anything I
mean you would have just borrowed it to
bring it it's in my eye my house yeah
exactly
well they gifted me a few items yes of
course yeah but in the in terms of
clothing yeah I mean they're they're uh
Isabelle I uses clothing as as they're
her shield her armor you know with which
she confronts the world so it's pretty
cool to have that to be a part of
character creation
um I they have not obviously Greenland
or maybe they have another season of
narcos Mexico do you know if your
character will be a part of we don't we
don't know any of what's happening
beyond good to I understand I want to
ask you actually go backwards if I'm not
mistaken you actually sort of worked
with Martin Landau
um and like I guess he somehow got you
into an actor studio or something or am
I wrong about this yeah the Actors
Studio
um can you started talking about how did
you meet Martin Landau how did this all
come about uh I was thinking at class
just uh I was beginning my my acting
studies and the teacher that was giving
me the class was a part of the Actors
Studio she spoke to Martin about me he
said she said there's this girl in my
class you should come see her so he came
to see me and invited me to be a part of
the studio and then he mentored me for
maybe five years first that's amazing
yes and second of all I mean he's such a
gifted or was such a gifted actor can
you sort of share what it was like like
learning from him and being you know
yeah i mean i think marty well first of
all marty was the biggest had so much
love for acting and was so passionate
but mainly he taught you about what
talent was a could do for you which is
like this high sensitivity that then you
learn how to you know how to pull from
how to use how to how to manage and
handle that was his main thing with me
he taught me you know the you're like
this wealth of emotions and sensitivity
and then how to access it he was very
gentle there encouraging i truly masks a
true master that's awesome before I run
a time I've been asking everybody what
TV show would you love to guest star on
what TV show um maybe I would have loved
to guest star narcos Columbia my last
thing do you remember your first movie
or TV show crush yes I can't tell you
because I work a lot with him oh really
I will not pressure you but that's a man
and that also has to be very weird yeah
it is cuz I always drop my coffee I
always spill my coffee just stumbling
everywhere